good afternoon good morning
we've had a
conversation of almost one hour and a
half
between me and
russian
foreign minister lavrov
also with the
participation of uh turkish
foreign minister mevluchoglu he indeed
provided
kind services and trying to approximate
the position of both
sides i came to these
negotiations with two
tasks the first one is to organize a
humanitarian corridor
from and to mariupol
this is the
the most difficult
location
at the moment
in terms of humanitarian situation and
the second task is to
agree on
at least a 24-hour ceasefire in order to
resolve all
emergency issues and needs of people who
are
caught by this war
as far as the first task
i sincerely hope that
mr lavrov will
communicate
with liaise with those in russia who
make these decisions
and the humanitarian corridor will
nevertheless operate
and i still keep hope that the russian
federation
from humanitarian
reasons from
empathy
human empathy to those who are suffering
in mariopol
and
will allow to evacuate
uh
babies those who suffer in mario paul
because of the lack of medications that
the russian authorities will allow
the for humanitarian corridor from
mariopol same way
as
humanitarian corridors as the which
operate from for example from suma to
poltava
we
can't stop
the war
if the country
which
started the aggression the attack
has
no will
willingness to do that today i heard
that ceasefire
is linked by the russian federation to
the implementation
of
the demands
put by president putin to ukraine in
connection to this i would like to
confirm
once again that ukraine
has not surrendered
is not surrendering and will not
surrender
we are ready for diplomacy we're
looking
for diplomatic solutions but until we
find them
we'll be
doing everest we'll be doing everything
to defend our land
our people from russian aggression
i hope that the format
we've had our
talks today in will be will continue i'm
ready for that
if the russian side is ready for a
serious
conversation rather than
repeating
used
propaganda
matrix
or statements against
ukraine all that we need today
is the
serious conversation
focused on specific subjects
no cliches as soon as the russian side
is ready
uh for this conversation i will be ready
to continue this conversation uh we'll
do everything possible
for peace to saving lives of our citizen
because
human life is the the most precious
things for us
think for us thank you
the director of international atomic
energy agency is going to arrive to the
talks
but
is russia still threatening with the
nuclear button yes
at the end of the meeting minister
lavrov touched upon the subject of
nuclear safety
and
he wants to
at least he
supported uh
trilateral consultation between
the
international atomic energy russian and
ukrainian participants i told him that
before the russian soldiers soldiers
invaded the territory of ukraine
everything was in order had been in
order with our nuclear power stations in
ukraine they were
reliable in
operations and ukraine has been
continues to be
responsible participation of all
verification mechanisms by ait and
non-proliferation
treaty all these lies there spreading
that they entered ukraine uh because of
the nuclear weapons uh
program uh it's all lies inspection the
international inspectors
haven't seen anything like this and
because things like that not happening
in ukraine have never happened and or
what russia
should do now
should
take away
their soldiers from the parisia and
chernobyl
nuclear plants and
that
[Music]
for minimal operations and allow
inspectors from international atomic
agency uh to inspect
any
uh
efforts to
observe power and
occupy territories
of nuclear
power plants is unacceptable if
they want to
impose any kind of
management on their site it will not
work so
briefly saying uh
i russia should demilitarize the nuclear
assets they're occupying now and
avoid any attacks and uh efforts to
seize any of these facilities and also
of gas infrastructure because it could
by seizing the this infrastructure it
would threaten the
nuclear assets we're ready for the open
dialogue with the international atomic
agency but on the principles i outlined
you